[Music]
what does it mean what does it mean
to be
at peace what does it mean
at
ease what does it mean
for our psychic storms to give way
to sunny skies what does it mean
to lay our burden down what does it mean
to find some redemption to find some
absolution what does it mean
to be in grace
it feels like these days
all of us are caught in psychic storms
we're all just
enveloped in a maddening chatter
a kind of excessive rumination a
self-consciousness
characterized by hyper vigilance and
neuroticism a proneness
to negative emotion inter-psychic
storms we're out of touch
with our bodies we are in a state of
[Music]
disease mental health epidemic no doubt
makes evident
what i think is
clearly intuitively apparent which is
that we're all in a state of alienation
and when more people die
by suicide then die from natural
disasters and armed conflict combined i
think it tells us that something is
broken
but how do we address what's broken if
we can't really see it how do we
quantify our interiority how do we fix
our psyche if our psyche by design is
sort of ineffable and metaphysical we're
so caught up in the trappings of a
materialist world view that we have
become alienated from our psyches and
our inner psychology is a domain we know
not we are strangers to ourselves we are
strangers in a strange land we are
anxious
we are caught up in the trivial we are
obsessed with overthinking and
rumination and we are locked inside
ourselves and we are not in a state of
ease
so what does it mean then
to find ease how do we finally then
[Music]
occasion
stillness
and
inner peace
well what is needed friends is a kind of
intervention a form of
knowledge known as knowledge by
acquaintance we cannot be told
what lies through the looking glass we
cannot be told what the matrix is
you have to see it for yourself chris
lethbe wrote about this he says
for a person trapped
in the hall of mirrors and anxiousness
and self-defeating narratives of anxiety
and depression they cannot be told how
to free themselves from those trappings
they have to be shown
how to free themselves from those
trappings stop trying to make art
they've said and just become
art there needs to be
a leap of faith there needs to be a
dying to who you were there needs to be
a psychological skydive there needs to
be a trust fall there needs to be
a
willingness to live in paradox we must
surrender all control in all of our
affordances and trust that we are safe
and we will land in a feather bed there
has to be a kind of slipping in the
banana peel only to find ourselves in a
place where we realize that everything
we feared was just a psychic storm the
only thing to fear is fear itself fear
is the mind killer so how do we kill
fear instead how do we find ease how do
we move into grace
we need to shake the snow globes of our
existential and ruminating rigidity we
need to get past the broken record
stories that we tell ourselves about
ourselves that are no longer serving us
we need to
move
into domains
where we are born anew to be twice born
and experience a virginal noticing of
the sensate world is to awaken the
mind's attention from the lethargy of
custom and redirected towards the
wonders of existence a virginal noticing
of the sensate world or michael pollan
calls a sense of first sight
unencumbered by knowingness is to be
twice born like the painter miro said in
order to see something
you must forget the name of the thing
you are seeing
[Music]
in order to see something you must
forget the name of the thing you are
seeing universes of possibility will be
disclosed gray will be infused by color
the invisible will be revealed and the
mundane will be blown away by awe
and in this castigating and slaying
an annihilation
of the psychic storms
we will find ourselves reborn
[Music]
and we will be
grateful and we will be whole
[Music]
and we will
be in this
ease no more
so this is our path to redemption
friends this is how we move past
[Music]
the ego that has become a tyrant
this is how we free the brave reckless
gods within us all because the
alternative
david foster wallace wrote is
unconsciousness the default setting the
rat race in the constant
gnawing sense of having had and lost
some infinite thing
so reclaim that infinite thing and you
will find ease and you will find grace
and you will find gratitude
you will find wholeness
i want nothing less for you friends and
i want nothing less for me for this
is our common
[Music]
you